moi je vous propose plutôt les
fourberies de scapin sur la scène de la
comédie française saluée par toute la
critique les fourberies de scapin un
classique revisité avec dans le rôle
philippe torreton révélation du film
capitaine conan de taverny geneviève
moll rosé mode dans ce bateau jérôme
hergault de riches marchands de nappes
qui rentre de voyage ils ont décidé de
marier leurs enfants mais pendant leur
absence
les jeunes gens ont déjà trouvé leur
bonheur c'est le valais de géronte
scapin que molière qualifie de fourbes
qui va tenter de sauver les jeunes gens
notamment aux soutirant de l'argent aux
pères parce que ton n'est pas qu'un
personnage positif à l'est comme peut
l'être le cas où des gens comme ça les
plus retors et il est hélas il alla la
vengeance tardive et tenace dans une
mise en scène très dépouillée de jean
louis denoit et des décors minimalistes
des fourberies servi par d'excellents
comédiens de la comédie française
et surtout par philippe torreton qui
dans la fameuse scène du sac atteint des
sommets de cocasserie ils se vengent de
géronde qu'il veut bastonner en jouant
une multitude de personnages c'est pour
tous et des amis des gérantes oui je
crois qu'à des dix trous et des ses
années à la faune eu une farce grinçante
mené à toute allure avec un scapin qui
fera date philippe torreton